hello everyone and welcome to another
spectacular game from round two of
defeated grand prix the second leg of
the grand prix that's currently being
played in belgrade uh serbia yeah it's
evided versus vladimir pedosev and it's
quite an impressive game uh really uh
just a huge huge fight with a lot of
theory involved you guys will enjoy it
uh so let's dive straight into it with
it has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 uh we have knight to f6 c4 e6
knight to c3 and of course everyone's
favorite the nimso indian defense bishop
the b4 and we say that of course this
can be met many different ways the a3
has been played quite a lot in the last
few tournaments that we've covered just
allowing black to double the double
white c pawn later on black can maybe
undermine it but black had struggle
uh converting this
into anything because white either one
or drew those games but here it goes for
the classical variation queen to c2 not
allowing black to double the the c pawns
and well now it's just mainly theory so
castles we have a3 bishop captures queen
captures the pawns are now nicely intact
and b6 black will now get this beautiful
diagonal for his light square bishop
bishop to g5 this is all uh main line um
main lines of the of the modern theory
bishop to b7 and now uh okay one uh
black you got a lot of development in
the bishop controls this diagonal but
white now plays f3 so this somewhat
limited the range of this bishop and at
some point white will execute e4
grabbing all of these squares for
himself so black of course has something
against this black will play d5 grab the
center as well even though if you play
the names of oregon's the name so you
should know the the line h6 h4 it's just
uh okay h4 is not of course mandatory
but h6 is played quite a lot and you
have to decide whether to go back
whether to capture or to play h4 and it
can get a little bit dangerous if you
don't know what's happening here for
example captures captures now you have
to deal with the knight being attacked
like let's say knight h7 now f4
defending the g5 pawn and preparing
queen to h3 and now it looks very very
dangerous because black might be getting
checkmated but there are some fine ways
for you to tackle this one is bishop to
e4 just not allowing anything to happen
to this knight later on we can shift the
bishop to g6 or just give back the piece
for the two pawns characters captures
and captures and now everything is
perfectly fine white does have the open
h file but if you know how to play this
uh you you should be perfectly fine so
just in case you play uh the names or
play against the names of quite a lot so
here d5 this is the standard way of
playing this and now you either play e3
or first exchange on d5 and then play e3
which is what the video does we have
captures captures now e3 and here rook
to e8 so this is now a backward spawn
and black will of course try to
take advantage of this bishop to b5 now
attacking the rook uh asking black to
play c6 and this will take away the c6
square from from the knight but also
close up
the bishop's range even further
so c6 now comes bishop to a4 and knight
beat the d7 and here uh there uh
there is a game where knight the h3 was
played but here we have knight to e2
also uh following one game uh but now
there is a move h6 and we are now in a
completely new territory so as a move 13
we have a completely new game
uh it also we have to mention that
bishop to a6 although it looks very
impressive prevents white from castling
and puts pressure on this knight on e2
we can just play knight g3 later on we
can play king to f2 bring the rook to e1
and uh as as soon as the opportunity
presents itself maybe something like
bishop c2 we can execute e4 and the
white is perfectly fine but okay here we
have h6 asking that it
you know state his intentions with the
dark square bishop and he just goes back
bishop to h4 bishop to a6 now putting
pressure on the knight not allowing
white to castle and now bishop to d1 and
this is a very strange move to play
especially if you're not
used to it because you've just
put even more pieces in between your
rooks and we all know you have to keep
your looks connected
and what what is the bishop even doing
here well it's actually extremely well
placed as you'll see in the game so
queen e7 now preparing to capture the e3
pawn there should be back to f2 again
not something you see every day bishop
on d1 bishop on f2
but here it works uh and now fedorsi uh
plays it very
in a very principled manner he just
pushes c5 it's a c6 is also a backward
spawn so we want to get rid of it and
also we want to capture here and take
advantage of everything piling up on
that e2 square and now uh the thing is
let's say you castle we're just going to
capture here and now you're not going to
be able to capture with the pawn because
the knight falls you can't capture with
the knight because the rook falls you
will have to capture with the queen and
maybe it's a little bit uh maybe it's a
little bit uh weird playing like this so
that it first place queen to d2 and now
it's going to be a little bit different
now if pawn captures the knight can
capture
and again it looks weird your king can't
really castle but with it has plans of
bishop to e2 and getting rid of the
bishop on a6 either by trading it or
forcing black to move and then he's just
going gonna castle safety play rookie
one push e4 uh and so on so here instead
we have rook eight to c8 ferocious says
all right i i you know agree with your
setup there doesn't seem to be any
immediate way of taking advantage of
this and now with it just castles the
safety we have knight to b8 now shifting
the knight over to uh to c6 then to a5
and then to c4 as that is pretty much
sure the the standard idea with the
nimzo we have rook to e1 and now knight
to c6 we have knight back to c3
and now knight to a5 going for that c4
square but now we just play b3 we deny
black the c4 square and now you can see
how the bishop on d1 although looking
very awkwardly there is doing a fine job
uh and uh
instead of b3 we could also consider
bishop to a4 i thought you guys might
enjoy this because we are asking black
what is your uh rook doing there on e8
and then black might say all right but
what about knights to c4 attacking the
queen
then we can play queen d3 now the knight
cannot move because the bishop hangs and
once the rook moves now we play b3 and
look at this
b5 attacking the bishop we're just gonna
capture here and after uh black captures
here we're gonna play knight captures on
b5 and we get this extremely complicated
position where the knight here is
hanging and it's not all that clear how
uh how how how to play this with black
but white should be better but okay has
a different idea he plays b3 we have
queen to d8 now uh and now comes rook to
c1 uh claiming that uh c file that is
very soon to be open we have rook to e6
preparing to double up on the c file and
now d captures on c5 saying that all
right you you have to capture with the
pawn because if you capture with the
rook then i'm just going to play e4 and
this is now very very unpleasant for
black once that rook moves we even get
e5 and uh now it's already white who's
dictating the tone of the battle so
after the captures on c5 we have b
captures and now knight to a4 putting
pressure on the c5 pawn rook e to c6
defending the pawn and now bishop to h4
and this is not a very very annoying pin
it will be hard to get out of uh
of course black will have to play g5 at
some point so here knight to b7
and here comes bishop the c2 we have
queen to a5 now offering a queen trade
because white is controlling a lot more
space and vidiq says this is uh well
much favorable for me so queen captures
knight captures and now rook c the d1 uh
putting pressure on that d4 pawn uh
imagine we can just capture here then if
we're captures we capture here we have a
great game so here black plays g5 uh
here d4 would also work it's a very very
good move but
i think fedors have just wanted to to
keep this pawn at bay on e3 and later
pile up on it saying that you will not
be able to take advantage of the
d5 that is currently maybe a weakness so
instead g5 was played bishop to g3 and
now rook to e6 now going after that e3
pawn
but this allows vidit this very nice
idea of bishop to f5 you can see that
ferocious offers uh
the exchange here uh but even though you
could uh play bishop to f5 right away
that
that's the move that divided played rook
to b1 is incredibly strong because now
uh
you can see that bishop to f5 is still
an idea but with the b4 move
being prepared and you know how b4 can
be devastating in a lot of situations uh
there's just not all that much black can
play if you if you play rook e38 you're
on pin we still play bishop to f5 and
now once this rook moves we play b4
that's the good stuff uh using the
knight as a tempo to advance the pawn
even further and now we would get this c
captures a captures attacking the knight
if the knight moves we get b5 in so
bishop to b5 attacking the knight and
now just b captures an a5 bishop
captures and rook to b7 with this
beautiful beautiful position for white
so even this is an auction but okay uh
it goes for the rook right away bishop
to f5 now comes knight captures on b3
this was philosopher's idea uh giving up
the exchange for uh for the bishop and
the pawn uh but now not uh rushing with
bishop captures because you will grab
one of the rooks at some point h4 first
uh we have rook c the c6 uh sorry not
rookie the c6 rook c to c6 and now of
course we capture one of the rooks
captured captures and now h captures h
captures and here black has a very
strong center here uh also has the past
c pawn so it could be very dangerous you
can see that the knight already controls
the the queening square the queening
square uh and with it um
we'll have to be very careful here
so king f2 uh we have to bring the king
into the game that's how the end game is
played and fedocip just continues uh
advancing the past c pawn so here bishop
to e5 we use the knight as a tempo to
grab control of these squares knight to
d7 attacking the bishop will bishop to
c3 and now we have bishop to b5
attacking the knight here knight back to
b2 and now knight to d
knight to d to c5 preparing knight to d3
so rook to h1 of course we're going to
use the open h file for our rooks look
at this bishop controlling this diagonal
imagine if rook that comes to h8 then
the other rook can come to h7 you know
there can be a lot of damage done here
so here knight the d3 with check and
interestingly the position here is uh
winning for for white and it doesn't
matter pretty much if you capture the
knight or you go king the g3 uh i will
show it uh okay we're maybe showing um a
a a little bit more lines than usual but
this is such a such a rich end game that
we just have to show it the idea here is
that after king to g3 okay knight
captures on b2 so now it seems that if
bishop captures the black just gets a
nice tempo on the bishop with c3 first
we play rookie chat check and now after
king f7 rook h7 check and it doesn't
matter what black does for example rook
g8 or rogue g7 check you can't go here
because of checkmate so you're gonna go
back now comes rook h1 threatening
checkmate and now okay d4 regarding uh
and attacking uh so now this is this is
a threat we're gonna play rook b7 now
this is the threat of checkmate and the
once the king moves just the bishop
captures on b2 and now what do you do
you can't advance because just rook
captures and b5 will capture the knight
will capture the pawn so here let's say
a6 would defend the bishop now comes the
bishop characters on d4 now we can even
give up the bishop because let's not
forget we are up the exchange knight
captures e captures and once the pawn
starts marching forward
rook h the h7 c2 and now rook h to c7
and that's it you either uh advance this
pawn bring your queen into the game then
rook the b8 is checkmate or you trade
here then rook captures and of course
it's a completely winning end game for
white so king g3 is definitely an option
but the line vidit chooses is also
winning but it's much much more
complicated than uh than king the g3 so
it's very interesting that vidiq chose
this one and you'll see why knight
captures on d3 c captures on d3 and now
rook to h8 and this is uh
not not the most precise way as the
bishop is hanging here it's better to
play bishop to e5 first and now the
bishop will be super safe here and now
we use the h file to lift our rooks but
okay uh here rook the h8 checked by
vidit king the f7 and now rook h7 check
and here is where um vladimir plays it
wrong he has to bring the king back to
g8 but this is all uh incredibly
difficult to spot so here king the e8
was played and this allows with it to
play his miracle move that uh i mean if
you guys have not seen the game and if
you guys spot this
uh
i i don't know you you must be rated at
least 2500
or more so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find if it's miracle
move while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh incredible idea and for those of you
who just want to enjoy uh the show it is
bishop to f6 almost but it's not uh
bishop to f6 is the idea but before that
we have to play the miracle move and
that is of course pawn to a4 and this is
such a such an incredible move that um
if you found it uh probably you thought
about bishop to f6 but let's uh before
we uh enjoy why a4 is so impressive uh
we first have to play bishop to f6 and
uh say okay why can't we just play
rookie seven a rook h1 rook h8 or
something like that the point is here
black has a very forcing rook c to check
and once the king moves rook c1 now we
are preventing the rook from going to h1
and also the d3 pawn is defended so we
cannot capture it we can't play d2 as
the knight captures it so here we don't
have anything better other than to
capture capture and then uh we are not
going to be able to win this game uh so
uh that being said
uh that's why a4 is so strong so our
main idea is to move the bishop away
from the defense of the d3 pawn but of
course black realizes this why would
black even bother capturing the pawn so
can't we play something else um
instead of capturing the pawn we could
let's say we play bishop to a6 we say
okay we're guarding the pawn but now the
bishop on a6 allows rook d to h1
so we can leave the bishop hanging and
once the bishop captures this rook
captures on a7 and there's no defense
here you are getting checkmated
regardless of what you play
another idea after this um
a4 move is that okay maybe you don't
want to play bishop to a6 maybe you
don't want to play bishop captures an a4
why not just trade we capture the bishop
white captures our bishop so let's check
that out if rook captures on c3 we're
gonna play a captures on b5 and now look
at this d2 very impressive stuff from
black but
rook captures an a7 and now after rook
to c1 we have b6 and wow uh the knights
on b3 will be blocking uh
the path for the black rook to guard the
b8 queening square so here rook captures
on d1 b7 and now we don't have rook to
b1 because the knight is so awkwardly
placed on b3 and after something like
rook to f1 check trying to get the white
king to capture to bring your queen into
the game with tempo we're just gonna
laugh in black's face play king to g3
and now after black brings a queen into
the game we can bring a queen or even a
nicer a rook into the game and say
checkmate so that's the idea here that's
why a4 is so strong there is no move for
black to play here your only way out is
to play bishop characters on a4 but now
we know that the bishop to f6 line is
now working because the d3 pawn is
undefended so brilliant stop by vidit
here uh he plays of course bishop to f6
and now what do you play here rook to a7
check
rook h1 or this is only one of the ideas
there are many others uh e5 is played
here uh but it doesn't really help okay
now the rook attacks the bishop uh
he wants uh white to capture the e5 pawn
so uh the d7 pawn is no longer covered
but video just plays bishop captures on
g5 now we have knight to c5 going after
the e6 square to try and get some
defenders in but now rook h1 ah we have
king to f8 we have to prevent being
checkmated now rook captures on a7 going
for rook to h8 to checkmate so king to
g8 uh what else are we going to do and
now that it plays e4 interestingly rook
here is also winning right away but with
it first plays this because it just
allows uh an extra square for his king
you don't want to you know get get in
the middle of a
serious combination and maybe get
checkmated so here d captures on e4 and
only now rook h the h7 and the black
king is now completely helpless knight
e6 goes after the bishop now bishop back
to d2 we have rook to c2 attacking the
bishop here now king e3 enjoying our
newly vacated e3 square e captures on f3
g captures and now bishop to c6 trying
to guard some squares here but it
doesn't matter rook hd7 attacks the
knight knight c5 and now just rook e to
c7 going after rook to c8 which will
result in checkmate and there is nothing
for black to do here black tries bishop
to b7 so both of the squares are covered
but now we just uh well win the piece
rook captures on c5 rook captures and
the rook captures on b7 and it was in
this position animal 55 that vladimir
pharosev resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here he had
done here he's down a piece and of
course this is completely winning for
white so incredible incredible game and
this is such a was such an exciting
moment after this knight the d3 check uh
like i said king g3 is winning uh but
knight captures on d3 that visit plate
is also winning
but so much more complicated and you
have to find this a4 move uh so
completely completely crazy game
but uh once again i'm very glad that i'm
able to present a nimzo indian defense
game that does not disappoint so this
was an incredible struggle both players
had some great great ideas and it was it
was just a really really good fight
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to wish a
very happy birthday to freddie flowers
and i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to mihael schwallen and i would
like to thank gregory bosco ivan
lewandowski and paul for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
grand prix checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day